so I've been trying to get your windows
mess there for a while I think you're
probably one of the best winners that
we've had because you're killing it
makings making six figures in property
doing well doing well full-time but also
super super knowledgeable you've
obviously been through the training yes
you've got a background in property
definitely and the disclaimer is that we
did not meet through training you
actually family yeah a hundred percent
say you are you're my brother-in-law so
why don't you just kind of give me give
a little bit of a lowdown because I know
you are strategically located we do a
lot of business together but your hide
away from the cameras so what are you
kind of like doing what's the background
yeah so basically the reason for the for
the for the low-key Nisour suppose is we
do a lot of deals and look at different
opportunities with multiple agents and
and multiple investors so a lot of the
times depending on what type of deal it
is you kind of want to keep it close to
your chest until it's ago so that's the
reason because you can't screw deals up
I've been to I mean I I film everything
I do pretty much yeah when you're
looking at big sites and you know and
you're filming and you're saying this is
what we're gonna do this is the plan
sometimes it can backfire definitely we
did a video together actually okay god
yeah and I know you're always recording
something but we had a private meeting
yeah I know I had I had videographers
around and you knew that filming but but
then what I published it you saw it and
you were like dude you're gonna take
that down that's so much a confidential
stuff in there oh yeah what do you think
of the way that I just share everything
that I'm doing I think it's great that
you share because you add a lot of value
and the things that you add value to the
people that they can take away and
actually run with and change their lives
so I think it's absolutely fantastic the
only things that I keep to myself mainly
are the potential opportunities and and
too much detail I suppose in that sense
or I say most rich people hide and
you're probably one of those people that
is the quiet The Millionaire Next Door
yeah
because I do because this about year I
know we've used this tactic is different
there's a lot of people that are very
successful in property you know you're
doing million dollar do what I say
dollar I've been hanging out because I'm
gonna be expanding to the US yeah but
you you know you're working on
multi-million pound deals and and most
people that are doing that they do hide
away they don't want people to see what
they're doing in case people copy them
where is so I'm really glad that you've
come on this yeah and yeah a lot of
times it's not necessarily copying I
suppose it's just you working on a lot
of pies if you don't want to lose them
you know in a year particularly the
multi-million pound deals you might get
you know three or four absolutely juicy
ones in a year the very few and far
between
yeah and when you get the meat just
don't mess them up easy I'll try see
them all the way through and that's the
only reason so so when when we kind of
when did we first I know we first met it
was in a family con environment yes but
when did you first start taking an
interest in like what I'm doing on the
property side geez to be honest I opened
my eyes to a different to a different
way of approaching a spoke of life and
career I suppose in a way because I was
generally a traditionalist I suppose in
the way that I've been I've been raised
not that it's a bad thing but you always
think yeah I want to do I wanna do my
own anymore but it's always trying to
figure out how to do more so I was
working very hard in my career but
actually I realized I can work very hard
in my career and still get paid and make
money and create generational wealth and
seeing how you operating a new targets
at the time and seeing how it's all
manifested through over the since the
whole period I've known you has been
absolutely fantastic over five years I'm
gonna be married five years six years
yeah I always respected you as a
professional you know I saw that you
really knew your stuff and sometimes I'd
ask you to look at deals for me and
things yeah you know chartered surveyor
been in the industry what about sixteen
years that's it so you've been in
property longer than I have lost a lot
of hair doing it yeah making a lot of
people rich right there's the key making
a lot of people which you've been in
property longer than I have and your
expertise in in certain aspects to the
business are better than me like when it
comes to cost management and
that sort of things like you're you're
streets ahead of May but you know when
we met you might have been better and
more knowledgeable in some areas but
then I'm making way more money did you
challenged me to be honest I remember
after I think we went from meals in
Union this is early early on and he said
bent so when he starts in your business
when you started you consulted exact I
have been saying I'm gonna start one I'm
gonna start work and now I was naturally
a very risk-averse person it was
actually been listen you do know you
know you know a lot of things your safe
pair of hands it's not necessarily
taking a risk if you know what you're
doing because you know what you're doing
you're really doing it for the people
and that was the first time I thought
he's right take this for a long time
Rick a lot of people rich so what's the
point in me just continuing to do that I
might as well get get rich as well yeah
make other people rich well I'll be
working with and everybody wins yeah and
I don't know when you work it because
now I wear family life but like you
wanted to be a basketball player yes and
dad dude and dad was like no geez hours
I was very very good at basketball don't
think of my height I had the springs in
my legs and and speed yeah and I thought
I was headed to the NBA I checked nearly
did yeah my dad was like no no you need
to go to school you need to go to school
yeah but our family like very much
preach this and it's not bad and don't
get me wrong I mean I mean mom and dad
your parents have done really well for
themselves you know and have come down
to the UK got good careers making making
good money yes done really really well
for themselves but the mindset and the
mentality is you know study really hard
and then get a really good job and then
save it's it's it's the old school -
yeah exactly and it's very similar I
think a lot of families of culture like
for example like with with the ages with
the Africans are you each go to screen
to be an engineer you need to be a
doctor you need to me
and it's always seems to be set in stone
before you even you know tick-borne I
suppose and I think so life is evolving
with the new generations coming up these
new ways to make money
to be entrepreneurial yeah and yeah
that's the first thing because I
remember I remember when we first met
and you said you know to me yeah I'm
gonna set my own business up soon
and I was like cool but then Amanda said
she was like yeah he has been saying
that for quite some years because always
thinking are you back to set your own
bridges in the next few weeks and do you
know what the thing is that in a way it
took me a little while to get to the
point where I was like right I'm out of
here
yeah and I'm setting off but it's still
me well being risk averse because a lot
of the projects that we do particularly
when you deal with multi-million pound
yeah really wouldn't be rushing things
being too greedy right so in a way it
took a while but it's been great and
it's a balance between being
conservative of your figures and
risk-averse but then at the same time
taking action yes and stepping out yeah
and I think I'm glad if you weren't
risk-averse if you were the same as me
then I probably wouldn't want to do
deals with odds I will deal with you
either silence and and and the great
thing is you know I've learned a lot
from you about about the constriction
and about cost management and you know a
lot from you but it's also been great to
kind of pass my entrepreneurship
definite but it's rubbed off but I still
make the family pay you do you do make
the family pay Samuel yeah yeah I mean I
remember when you know early early on my
dad paid to come to the first one you
know one of the four or five years ago
and then we came on we paid to come on
the course and what I loved the
knowledge that you were sharing so
whilst I was in the industry for you
know 15 16 years now at the time you
know how to do it you know how to
deliver put these things that you don't
know as to how to make money from it for
yourself yeah and those are the things
that definitely learned from you and
they were worth paying for - yes very
enlightened to talk to me a little bit
about the training because I know that I
know not just you but the whole family
like even recently I think a few months
ago Melissa anyway yeah and my dad I
came back but Melissa came for the
and she advanced training like she went
straight in but but she's going straight
a little a little sister yeah has paid
thousands of pounds you have her own
pocket to go on training that was
created by me yes and some people might
look at that and I say why would you not
and obviously you know just because it
struck me I created it doesn't mean that
I'm always doing all the training but
why would you not just as chair of the
company step in and let your sister come
for free because it's you know it's
worth the money basically if it and also
I think if you've got skin in the game
and you pay some yeah you are going to
act on it yeah that's the big thing for
me as well cause sometimes people say to
me you know Sam where did you did you
[ __ ] really work and I'll say yes I I
think it's up if it's dim I wouldn't let
my own family
yeah just tell you in a reef was Jerry
but no it was that good and people might
think this is crazy because you know I'm
always young makeup if anybody asks me
about property I say well I think you
need to go to the crash course yeah and
they always think ours just because his
brother-in-law
no no it's generally because I think
that the training is amazing
yeah and it's then gets down to your own
mindset as to how you're gonna take the
ball and run with it
yeah after you've done it because you
can get given all the tools but if
you're just gonna let them sit there and
you know and gather rows then you will
complain but even even mom and dad are
taking like a big career change now have
gave you focusing you've now move you've
now leaving our moved by Wickham who've
now which I probably would have knowing
my own self I'd never would have done
yeah but now with with what sort of
rubbed off and and the principles I have
learned not John the crash course but
just through knowing you I decided to
take the the the outs of character steps
I suppose yeah now my character that's
all sensor so I won't know in a minute
move on to a little bit about what
you're actually doing now and how you're
making your money exactly what kind of
deals you know and I know you you know
you're making very very good money but
before we do that like talk to me a
little bit about your previous
experience as a
cost manager chartered surveyor yes
you're black what did you learn exactly
what were you doing in that yeah so I
started off I was very fortunate I
started off as an intern at a
construction company working as a
trainee quantity surveyor went to you
knew for four days a week when sorry
went to uni one day a week works for the
other four four it took a little longer
it takes about five six years to get
qualified in the degrees qsr but you
learn a lot on site from actually you
know measuring in the trenches speaking
to the bricklayers seeing how things are
put together how to manage your costs
how to program that kind of thing and
you soak it all up as you go and you
learn throughout the whole process what
makes a good project what makes a bad
project and because I was a curious I
had to make money for my company which
is obviously great because now I have to
make money for my own company and for my
clients as well that that I provide
service for that was the joy that was
the start of the journey so you
literally so you're dealing with
builders project managers investors
developers and kind of the middleman
really making sure everyone's Excel yeah
projects run smooth projects run on time
which is a really stressful job it is it
is and really hot yeah and when I
started is this two things it's couldn't
this construction contracting and then
there's consulting yes I started off as
a contractor and I just had to make the
Builder money because I was working for
the Builder and then I made the
transition into consulting which is now
I'm hand-holding developers hands and
helping them procure sites build on them
and then obviously let them make sure
that they achieve their profits
yeah and the targets for for each
project so doing that like did you feel
that we every year were you learning
loads or does it get to a point after a
few years where you kind of know
everything can you repeat yes so in
terms in terms of every single projects
different and there's a up to a point
you learn the technical skills and
technical skills can be finite but
there's the soft skills and there's
different pressures with different types
of clients different apps for invest our
negotiation yeah whether it's a public
body whether it's a private entity how
big the deal is how much money they have
or if it's a really tight
was really tight margin so it's got the
all that different pressures around them
so each one you get to a point where you
know a lot but then it just comes down
to how do you cope with the pressure how
you handle it and how you deliver the
projects and that's that's the I think
that's the key after a good unusual you
know you sieve it you've got a good CV I
mean you've worked with someone how
confidentially it's but you work with
some very big client I have yeah well
it's not so bad now because obviously
I'm running my own business I was gonna
say whatever the hell I want blood work
words I've worked with some awesome
clients since your name in history of
elihpa so yeah I've worked with land
securities well one of the mass you know
yeah a lot one of the largest yeah
property developers and and a securities
businesses basically in terms of
property in the UK I've worked with
British land I've done some work for on
Amazon projects big bill is she holding
a hand and delivering projects I've
worked with developers called news I
remember thinking when you were doing
what you were doing I remember thinking
me and band together could make some
serious serious money but my problem
with you was always the your the mindset
yeah of being to say so it's like oh one
day I'm gonna do my own business or one
and I just thought I probably couldn't
work with that because I'm so fast-paced
yeah I probably couldn't work with
someone that was just so such a talker
when it comes to business so I was
always a bit like but I really respected
you as a professional and I'm we asked
you to look at projects and stuff and
then I know you stopped you did some
training and you also started reading a
lot you you read Grant Cardone book I've
written a lot of G's oh yeah I've read a
lot of books and then you could take
your mindset but I think I must help you
change the little you came to the crash
course you didn't you did a bit of
investments in residential yeah you
bought that little house what was that
'only in Leeds yeah and which when well
yeah well yeah we actually kept that one
obviously reinvesting the others what
big deals what did you pay for that
we paid hundred hundred thirty-five and
now it's worth I think it's like hundred
and seventy on vacati so it's gone up a
little bit it's the cash flow that's
what that's how much again rent just
over it one thousand pounds eleven fifty
I think it's well 1150 but that is
guaranteed rent yes
you've got no bills no maintenance yeah
nothing because it's someone else we've
we've got a really good tenant in there
yeah assisted living a really good time
but you kind of almost took what we what
we did now on the commercial stuff it
was that thinking it would exactly that
think you do that because when you when
you go into commercial property you
don't want to be dealing with loads of
tenants with loads of areas like you
just want one tenant if you've got a
massive big student block you want to
get the university to rent it off for
you you don't want to get all the
students in it so people don't think
like that in residential but you do
almost took commercial mindset brought
that into your into your residential
property which is cool the thing that
really attracted me to want to work with
you is we've got the experience you're
really good at what you do but then when
you mines that side shift in you did a
bit residential came to the crash course
did some training and then what happened
talk to me about Saudi Arabia yes so
with the residential thing I was
thinking yeah this is great but we could
10x this and just do on commercial on
commercial no properties rather than
they're doing the bike let's in HMOs and
stuff and it was all because of the
principles that I had been exposed to
your but one of the things you taught me
was a big deal is just as difficult as a
small yeah exactly you know so I'd see
you making millions not for yourself but
for your clients and I'll be thinking
geez like doing anything you're doing
everything it's yeah and you don't go to
bed at night you know so yeah we I mean
with the Saudi Arabia thing I thought
jeez you know what I'm going to make as
much money as I possibly can over three
four year period and then comes come and
start doing it back here for myself as
in developing yeah because I knew I
could do it at all the tool sets and I
just thought you know I forget good
there were three quarters of a million
pounds I can start doing the big deals
and just recycling you know my own cash
its he Colin said a man's been your
people willing to invest with you here
I've thought of myself and she's you so
yeah yeah because I'm thinking because I
kind of it am aren't you
a little bit for deals because I was
getting at this time I was gay because I
bought the casts all yeah and I was and
I was often asking you for advice
yeah and I was thinking you know you
really helpful and then when when you
literally were about to sign a contract
yes you move and leave your family at
home yeah to move to Saudi Arabia like
not for good but for potentially 3-4
years I thought number one I'm gonna
miss BAM as a brother and as someone I
could get advice on my first of all but
number two your mindset change so much
because before you were kind of like you
know are not comfortable job comfortable
but now I'm gonna be in the desert and I
just thought you seemed to agree
different I was a I was ready to get a
get uncomfortable or just ready to get
the fired comp
yeah and then I thought what if the
fires come I'd rather do some business
together yes so that's when we spoke
about look let why don't we do joint
ventures together yeah I've got the
money to put into the bills you've got
the expertise to oversee and everything
you can take a profit share and let's
start doing deals together and since
then we've been working on some fast
food race it's been an amazing amazing
contact combination yeah you know those
guys and Jesus been great so far and I
think it's gonna be even greater you
know as the years go by
ya really looking forward and we should
have a company together we did which is
called Mac leads yeah then we looked out
your Ben machaca Nyanga on Samuel leads
so we came together Mac leads and what
does Mac leads do so mcLeese is a
property development vehicle for them
for large deals and we only focus on the
big stuff so I'll bring stuff to you and
you'll literally be like dude come on
like it's like no commercial message to
come early get out of my face man you
end that on Murphy's you might be
interested potentially yeah yeah but
that's good because you because the
thing is and you could spend all your
time we could joint venture together on
a deal that was 500 thousand with a
hundred grand profit and you're thinking
I don't I don't want to spend all my
time on a small day okay it needs to
make sense it's all it's all relative
because
as you hit the nail on the head earlier
where he said the small deals take just
as much effort as the big deals yeah but
if you know what you're doing you can do
it he knows there's no problem with that
and now with where we're at we're
comfortable taking on the big deals
because we know what we're doing yeah
and but the thing is for me I've worked
my way up to that yes you went in
working for other people do big deals I
started doing small deals I've worked my
way up to do big deals yes you've helped
me a little bit but now I mean we've
just completed on on with that we've
just built a bunch of houses yes we did
yet but you've been helping which you've
been helping on you've also got involved
with the castle good going go with
everyone same to me no what about the
castle what's happened that Castle I was
thinking this song Jesus just to in
what's the space is all I can say watch
this bad just have to be patient and
resolve the car looking good how you
feeling about the end result of the
castle extremely confident that was kind
of a gut feeling I think is there is one
of those a lot of people would have
walked away because it scared from the
outside yeah
but knowing what you like you build a
maverick smart and I can see if I can
see if it deals good or not yes um you
know but you've been you've been
whipping things up to speed with that
yes we actually have so many problems
definitely yeah but yeah that's the
thing I think the problems aren't
necessarily an issue yeah you just have
to know how to manage the problems and
manage the risk if you know how to do
because it's always gonna be risk is
always gonna be problems but it do you
have the skills and the expertise to be
able to manage it yeah and that's that's
what it was a lot of people just ride
away you to get on it's gonna be great
yeah and we and we look at deals a lot
like we were out just last week yes
looking at some man yeah we had a full
full day out in Stoke and every time we
go to stoke it's always wet and rainy
and young deer yeah but it was a good
day because we looked at some really
good sites would you two go out again
yeah when you do in whaling property as
well because sometimes people say to me
you know how much do you earn in
property how much do any property and
it's like listen my property business
just gives me a wage any money above
that just go straight back into buy more
property yes so what do I make you
probably it depends on what they also
did that yeah a hundred percent like
this year probably will be a very very
profitable year or grid this way
I'm earning a good number we can do my
deals you pay yourself yeah from the
property business you pay yourself a
six-figure salary yeah and that's just a
wage but regardless of how well the
business does you know you're not gonna
sue me blah you know what I'm gonna
spend a million pounds on a holiday I
know you don't the world comes down to
that think undercover Secret Millionaire
no I'm saying as in you know III don't
splash on like a million pound holidays
like you say no you know you never
comfortable last yeah just modest send
your kids to quit school live in High
Wycombe live a cop but not but not but
sometimes people say to me you know why
are why you only wearing that that that
outfit you know what that's that's a
poor person the outfit just because I'm
wearing something but I'm like you know
why because my dad still not even
because of that no because that but
because I don't have to know it yeah
that's true I don't have anything anyone
know like I'm just quite happy wearing
whatever I want to well I mostly wear
nice clothes today tomorrow I might just
yeah I just I'm just cool man even just
having to see that's always been a
baseline with you though cuz but then I
I know you personally and that's always
been you what's that just chilled out
baseline I just a guy I'm not trying
pressed an interesting guy I'm making a
lot of money in property I love it we
don't really touch stuff in this we can
make a million pounds no often depending
on the deal but like generally speaking
or at least pull all of our money out
and then rent it out on it on a large
scale number yes you know so so it's
just like I don't have to impress
anybody I just I'm happy making my money
the only reason I do this YouTube
channel and teach people how the
training company is because I always
vowed if I became successful right and I
wasn't gonna hide away if I became
successful I was gonna show her there's
exactly what I did and help other people
do because I don't think comp it's a
competitively I think collaboratively
same with you I'm not thinking I'm not
going to each my family because then
they'll get all the deals forget that
it's my family and we can do deals
together and how I am with my family
with you is exactly I encourage the
family
the same with everybody it's a baseline
yet everyone's basin you know so so what
she plans them for you know over the
next 12 months
yeah well put it this way this morning
the reason I know we were a little bit
late and that what a part of the reason
was I got a couple of really good yes I
slept at and all of a sudden I'm like I
know I'm doing tomorrow now I'm going to
be heading towards Hemel Hempstead
looking at you know two three properties
no I yeah I'm not gonna say too much now
because again I don't like people sniper
in my yes but yeah I think the two of
these three are most likely gonna be
what worked up really I'm excited I
can't wait to see these off-camera and I
do everything on camera I get this
strategically you don't want to put
everything on corrode it sound cool what
you be my working me so five the last
sort of six months one season was a
nightmare although using a human but now
I'm just joking this be great although
although Amanda did warn you to be
careful
yeah I met a man Amanda rang me and just
before made his mandible defend doesn't
knows my wife your your city yeah my
yeah my sister yeah just like Abed Pam
just thought like she knows someone's
really different when he's at work you
know like he's happy and smiley with her
in the house and everything but once it
gets to work he's stone-cold killer yeah
yeah I can be pretty really good yeah
and I was like that's a cab I won't be
plenty difficult people
oh sure be alright I've also made work
with odd with up with some people but
yeah it was just business because I
guess if you're managing my projects
yeah yeah and Amanda's probably thinking
like oh you know man I think I'm I think
I'm pretty easy to work with
you are very easy to work with to be
honest and you're great to work with as
well and you've had to make some
difficult some difficult calls and
you've had to make some difficult
the game development is part of the game
and also manages all expertise you're
saying if everything was easy everybody
would be doing it right yeah no so
worked hard to get to where I am now I'm
just maximizing reaping the rewards of
all the hard work and expertise that I
have making sure that you know returns
are made you know for my clients we
should which is one of you you're the
main one I suppose of the moment format
leads and for all the other people that
were working on with as well working
with some good people and yeah that's
what Mike leads is we take the hassle
out from the investors you make the hard
calls we make sure everything's done so
if people are doing like and if people
are doing like development stuff or
they're looking at doing sort of like
building houses from scratch or do make
conversions that's where your company
comes in and just manages the whole
thing and takes the headache away which
is awesome and let can tell you there is
a lot of headache because you do it like
you say you have to handle a lot of
rubbish yeah I'm a lot of people
sometimes yeah yeah it's part of part of
being a pro ya know what you do it it is
and you've got to know what you're doing
and that's why I teach people you know I
can't keep going yeah that's the
knowledge the knowledge yeah so that's
why I admire what you do because just
because I'm teaching is just how do you
make money yes and I think that's what
you saw because you had the skills a lot
of people do there's surveyors and
brokers and solicitors they have they
know all about the subject but they just
don't know how to monetize it actually
make money yeah so it's great to see you
bringing your skills alive actually
making good money it's been awesome
working with you I'm excited to work
with you throughout the next cat hey
this is definitely space is definitely
you're also man with better thanks
[Music]
you
[Music]